nous sommes au théâtre du prisme à l
ankou et ça tombe bien qu'on soit dans
un théâtre puisque c'est de théâtre que
je vais parler avec mon invité marie
sylvia manuel m'a décidé à manuel est à
la fois une actrice metteur en scène et
directrice artistique elle est auteur et
puis on va parler d'elle parce qu'elle
est aussi la fille de deux immenses
comédiens robert manuel et claudine
koster marie sylvia manuel et mon invité
marie c'est bien manuel bonjour bonjour
alors se faisait au prisme c'est un
théâtre
et ça tombe bien c'est un théâtre el
loco ça tombe bien puisque vous êtes
essentiellement est totalement mais avec
beaucoup d'activités de tête si vous
êtes à la fois aux prises vous êtes
metteur en scène vous êtes directrice
artistique du festival celui de bons
pour loger tous ces privilèges mais vous
êtes auteur aussi on compare à d'autres
de votre dernier disque s'appelle
nouvelles d'autres tombes sont des
textes d'ailleurs pour pour lire ou pour
dire et puis et puis un autre livre
aussi que vous aviez écrit avec votre
père robert busnel dont on va parler
aussi
évidemment c'est lui qui était son
maître et son dieu qui était qui
témoignait alors peut-être d'abord un
mot puisque c'est l'actualité de ce
festival de beaufort laborie alors c'est
un festival tout nouveau puisqu'il a 3
ans donc c'est encore un bébé si je puis
dire qu'ils s'appellent marché donc
trois ans merci à la mairie de montfort
l'amaury à l'office du tourisme des
monts fort parce que sans eux le
festival ne pourrait pas avoir lieu et
dont je crois que ça a plu monsieur le
maire salua plus le public public ça lui
a plu c'est d'autant plus important et
donc notre principe c'est qu'il y ait
des spectacles vraiment très éclectique
pour tous les âges afin de donner de
l'importance de la saveur et du relief à
cette ville extraordinaire qui est
montfort l'amaury il s'est investi 3 ans
qui est aussi un peu turbulent
d'ailleurs comme un enfant 3 e ri c'est
vrai alors ça va un petit peu partout on
a aussi bien ça commence vendredi 11
samedi 12 et
dimanche 13 mai mai prochain donc c'est
bientôt bientôt il y aura une élection
même temps à peu près mon rhume est plus
importante
voilà tout le monde ne parle que du feu
bien sûr alors le premier spectacle
parce que tous les jours et y avoir des
spectacles du matin jusqu'au soir
le vendredi nous allons avoir une sorte
de visite un petit peu spectaculaire ou
aux flambeaux puisque le thème du
festival c'est mon fort insolites vous
eh bien on va avoir une grande visite
avec des étapes musicales théâtrales
poétique on va un petit peu connaître
les les mystères un petit peu de
montfort l'amaury parce que c'est une
ville centenaire et vous savez que dans
toutes les courses à mais c'est
merveilleux et dans toutes les cours
européennes
il y à un monfort il y à un amaury c'est
extraordinaire et c'est même un monfort
qui a créé le parlement anglais ouais
donc monfort est très riche vraiment
riche culture l avance écoutez c'est une
belle histoire et dont il ya beaucoup de
lieux on peut faire des spectacles et
alors il ya une participation aussi
d'amateurs
si vous avez un casting du jury il va y
avoir un autre voilà si vous êtes encore
égouttez le principal c'est qu'on que
n'importe qui de n'importe quel âge
s'il a travaillé quelque chose un texte
une chanson à 1000 quelque chose d'une
expression pe scénique
il est le bienvenu pour faire un
deuxième question parce que je viens
premier le samedi 24 mars après midi au
cinéma local donc le théâtre musical de
montfort l'amaury et là ou prou de monde
a sa chance
effectivement c'est je crois que ça fait
du bien aux personnes de se retrouver
sur la scène d'un vrai théâtre et s'ils
sont choisis s'ils sont retenus pour
leur sérieux pour leurs charmes pour
leur présence et bien feront partie en
public du festival le samedi 12 mai est
là disait vous avez beaucoup de
deux casquettes qu'on lit et laquelle
vous préférez au fond c'est l'actrice
il ya la mise en scène là c'est encore
autre chose je crois qu'être elle être
interprète je crois que c'est le plus
jubilatoire
ah oui c'est plus jubilatoire parce que
on a travaillé auparavant avec un
metteur en scène qu'on a estimé j'espère
qui est patent qui a donné des idées etc
et puis au moment d'être avec le public
c'est vraiment une joie profonde et puis
c'est une complicité ya un terme très à
la mode qu'on appelle interactivité pour
moi le théâtre le spectacle vivant c'est
de l'interactivité j'appellerais ça moi
de la complicité
donc voilà cette complicité quand on est
au moment là au moment m
avec le public c'est le cpv risée
formidable pour le public aussi
j'espère que les acteurs evala s'était
conclue il ya beaucoup de chansons dans
les spectacles
que vous faites non oui c'est vrai il ya
beaucoup de musique d'écouté geagea
colette renard ya au moins il ya eu des
choses comme ça
là vous avez fait un spectacle
exactement partir en tournée tout à fait
écoutez moi j'adore la musique c'est
indispensable c'est vital c'est donc
quand j'ai le privilège de pouvoir
travailler avec des musiciens en direct
d'avoir des compositeurs je ne m'en
prive pas et jusqu'à présent ça toujours
été le cas alors c'est le bonheur il ya
une une photo des activités je ne peux
pas encore parler vous êtes aussi
enseignante oui chacun fait ce qu'il
faut juste pour l'oreille musicale pour
être un bon comédien
eh bien écoutez il me semble il me
semble parce que c'est vrai qu'on parle
de la musique des mots sans oublier qui
a le font parce qu'un grand texte il ya
le fond et la forme
par exemple une amie et moi qui
collectent et cette requête une actrice
est patente
c'est un spectacle actuellement sur le
victor hugo politique avec des tailles
et le merveilleux je peux vous dire que
c'est vrai que le fond est merveilleux
parce que c'est très très très bien
écrit et donc la musique des mots
participe au sens et je crois que tout
bouquin toute chose lui si on le dit
oralement
si ça ne supporte pas leur âge je crois
que c'est mal écrit vous même quand vous
écrivez un nouvel d'autres tombent c'est
pour lire ou bourdy oui
vous faites comme vous faites un gaulois
vous jouez comme le camarade je faisais
écouter oui il ya un autre bouquin sur
des nouvelles
encore une fois c'est une sorte de
déformation que j'ai tout d'un coup on
est captée par une voix par une manière
de dire et par des mots et des maux qui
sont qui sont bien écrits je crois que
le style est une musique mais avec du
fond des chansons il y aussi souvent
dans vos spectacles vous mettez en scène
dont vous êtes à l'origine enfin à
l'origine desquelles vous êtes c'est
souvent des hommages justement on parle
du goût en 2002 on m'a commandé un
spectacle pour le cv de rendre des
hommages non mais oui mais pour les pour
les dates de naissance voyez vous voilà
deux en 2002 c'était 1802 la naissance
de victor hugo
en 2008 j'ai fait 1688 la naissance de
marivaux goldoni en 2007 pour 1707 le
cornet en 2006 pour la naissance en 1606
je préfère les sens des idées des autres
parce que j'étais engagé là c'est pour
ça non mais je préfère les naissances
est désormais allée commune boration non
mais c'est vrai que ça fait ça permet
aussi de rendre hommage
évidemment c'est ça qui est passionnant
et oui par exemple le fait travaillant
aussi des merveilleux texte avec des
musiciens
j'ai monté avec bernard dhéran will have
art merveilleux vraiment remarquable
vraiment remarquable et il m'a fait
l'honneur de faire un achat est patent
et il chantait parce que j'avais fait
avec des musiciens en direct une il
avait composé une des chansons
originales avec mu parole de molière
mais ça va très bien ça se marie très
bien mais molière adoré chanter
il ya eu des mises en scène corneille
avec merveilleux parce que c'est pile
c'est l'espèce et ça c'est formidable et
les grands textes inspire toujours on ne
peut on est jaloux le tripod jamais
c'est par amour qu'on fait tout ça et
c'est par amour que les idées viennent
vous pourriez pas trahir je pense les
hôtes et revues d'où vous venez
alors évidemment on vous en parle
toujours bbc belle histoire enfin vous
êtes on dire nos fonds de la balle on
dit ça comme ça écoutez on dîne enfin
moi j'aime scier du théâtre en tout cas
écouter une balle une bague oui
absolument
vous êtes vous êtes la fille de robert
manuel il voulait un secteur de claudine
coster ils m'ont soulagé ou merci de les
citer ça fait toujours extrêmement
plaisir évidemment alors peut-être que
les plus jeunes nous ont oubliés
peut-être qu'on voit encore dans des
films comme une amie bien sûr avec le
rififi chez les hommes les jules dassin
et tout ça c'était d'ailleurs dans la
scène du film la première longue scène
au moins onze minutes où il y as sans un
bruit sans un mot une scène de
cambriolage qui a été reprise d'ailleurs
dans d'autres films mais écoutez oui
c'est merveilleux d'avoir eu ce
filiation là pendant longtemps vous avez
par songe à faire du terrain oui c'est
vrai jusqu à 23 ans je voulais être
faisait d une maîtrise d'histoire de
l'art j'aimais tout ça je voulais avant
je voulais être coiffeuse je voulais
vétérinaire elle est archéologue et puis
c'est en visitant le metropolitan museum
de new york
mon frère était lisse au lycée français
comme professeur de français je suis
tombé sur une peinture qui m'a
absolument confondues confondues c'était
un vermeer une jeune femme à la lettre
et je le dis mais où apprend t-on
d'aussi belles choses on m'a d'histoire
de l'art dont j'ai fait l'histoire de
l'art et police a mené au théâtre ce
n'est un jour votre père vous a dit
voilà j'ai un assistant qui sont venus à
bout de cinq ans j ma maîtrise
je voulais travailler j'en avais un peu
marre faut bien le dire j'étais voir
papa puisque j'étais déjà dans le coup
mais j'étais la 83e roue du carrosse
vous savez je passais pas relâche deux
heures bon je dis papa écouter ce que je
peux aider il me dit ça tombe bien mon
premier assistant me dit je te prends à
l'essai est ce que c'est un avantage
évidemment enfin évidemment vous avez
baigné là dedans depuis votre votre
enfance mais est ce que c'est un
avantage d'avoir des parents célèbres
dans un métier où on se bat c'est
difficile quand on va à l'école et quand
vous tapez dessus n'ont peut-être pas
peut-être pas rarement m'enfin ça m'est
arrivé mais bon c'est comme ça s'est
fait taper dessus donc j'étais aussi non
non mais c'est rien ça arrive dans
toutes les écoles j'ai tout ça non mais
en revanche quand on n'a pas pas par
exemple reconnu et aimé ça ça touche
beaucoup
oui quand il m est ce que c'est déjà une
carrière après dans le même secteur
écoutez je n'ai aucune importance
écoutez moi c'est mon tremplin c'est mon
aide
si je l'avais pas eu j'aurais rien
appris et je continue encore à apprendre
et quant à chaque fois je fais des
choses il ya des choses qui me rappelle
mon paix et c'est pour moi une fondation
extraordinaire un tremplin terrible donc
au contraire c'est une joie c'est une
joie ça veut rien dit on ne peut pas
faire les mêmes choses que de charron et
tant mieux mais en tout cas que si on me
dit ah j'ai bien connu ton père tu me le
rappelle etc
ça me gonfle de fierté qu est ce que ça
a beaucoup changé le théâtre depuis de
votre enfant sont vos questions en
question beaucoup de la façon de jouer
par exemple le cinéma c'est pas écouté
moi déjà je dirais que samassa a
beaucoup changé ma vie puisque quand
j'étais petit je détestais voir ma mère
se faire embrasser par des messieurs
hussein évidemment ça me bouleverse
on ne comprend pas ce qui se passe après
oui on comprend qu'ils ont se font
brasser soi mais non c'est pas agréable
mais ont écouté le principe on a
tellement de talent écoutez dernièrement
nos petits français là jean dujardin
entre autres mais c'est mal
extraordinaire marion cotillard mais on
a tellement de talent en scénariste ans
en réalisation acteurs que c'était
absolument formidable
et donc je crois que le talent n'a pas
de temps n'a pas d'époque
alors c'est vrai que nous et nos
oreilles maintenant si on se repasse un
enregistrement de 18
en 2009 100 de sarah bernhardt on est
positivement étonné de que ç'a eu des
succès mais d'un autre côté quand on se
laisse à l'est cette musique du temps eh
bien il ya un certain charme daté mais
certain charme le temps passe trop vite
notre famille est un manuel on est
obligé de se quitter mais peut-être
qu'on va se revoir pour vous en parler
très sont déjà passés à ce vide son
passé ça alors on fait comme les dates
du festival de montfort l'amaury endredi
11 samedi 12 dimanche 13 mai et le
samedi soir nous allons jouer à 21h30 à
la nuit aux flambeaux en bas des ruines
de la duchesse anne
attention il y aura le jazz band de
colombes qui fait sa comédie avec un
grand spectacle de jazz avec les plus
grands de chansons de spectacles de
cinéma et les gens devront trouver les
petites faims
tout ça ce sera complice non pas
attractif vivement le mois de mai
écoutez avec les et merci beaucoup merci
à vous